In this section, we're going to take a look at light properties
and settings and how they work.
So let's get started.
In Unreal, we have several different options
to be able to change the look and feel for your light.
First up, we have intensity, which
controls the overall strength of your light.
We also have intensity in units.
You'll notice in the point light, rec light,
and spotlights, we have unitless, candelas, lumens,
and EVs to choose from.
EVs stand for exposure value, and they're
the relatively newer option in this category.
100 watts equals 1,600 lumens.
EV exposure value, which means you can set your intensities
in a relative stops or power of two increments.
Directional light or sunlight is what it's mainly used for,
can be defined and used in that particular intensity
units as lux.
We have other settings, such as directional lighting
intensity, attenuation, use temperature, source radius,
source angle, inverse square fall-off, and IES profiles.
And we're going to talk a little bit about this upfront
so you can understand a little bit how
some of the options that you have at your fingertips.
So let's go ahead and go to Unreal,
and then we'll get back to these slides.
So in Unreal, we have several different lights to choose from.
I just recently just popped a rec light in here.
We're going to move him over to the side.
We'll talk about him in just a bit.
But you'll notice in every single one of your lights,
and this one being a spotlight,
that one being the rec light,
you'll notice there is an area of attenuation
that is shown in our light settings here in our details.
So if I change my attenuation,
it's basically the area of influence.
And you'll see our cone change in the particular case
of the spotlight.
When it comes to the rec light,
you'll also see that change
as I go and decrease or increase this.
This is basically your area of influence.
We'll see intensity in the case of this rec light.
And we'll see that there's candelas, unitless, lumens,
and EV, as we mentioned before.
You can also control the color.
The source width and the source height are unique
when it comes to the rec light
and allows me to change its shape.
Now you'll notice when I change its shape,
it also will lose energy based on size.
This is determined on how strong
you've placed your intensity on that light.
So if I change the shape,
I'm changing the shape of this light over,
you can think of it as over that surface.
And I'm stretching the light beyond the amount of strength
that's available for the size that it's now become.
The rec light is probably one of the most expensive lights
you can work with.
Because in theory and how it works,
or I should say more on the way that we have created it,
is it works like a series of point lights
trapped within this square or rectangle shape,
whatever you choose to make it.
So it's really how that works.
It is the more expensive light.
But I like to use it as much as possible
because it works great as a fill light
and allow you to get some really great lighting
quickly and fast.
The directional light is typically your primary light
when it comes to your environment lighting.
And I mean that as when it comes to
if you want a more realistic environment output.
Now we are using Lumen, you'll see a little bit of noise
and we'll cover a little bit about that later.
That does happen currently in some aspects in some areas,
especially when it comes to certain materials.
And there are CVARs that can correct some of that.
So I can move my light, my directional light,
and it works with my atmosphere.
The reason why this is working so nicely and smoothly
is when you first start a scene,
I'm going to create a generic scene really quick.
You can connect your light and your other values together.
So if I just did a quick new level and kept it empty,
and we'll review this later
because we want to talk about light mixer
and the environment light mixer.
I'm just going to hit create
and say don't save for the moment.
So I have to go to my window.
I'm going to go to my environment light mixer.
And you'll notice we don't have those things set up
in our scene as our fog and other things in our outliner.
None of that is showing up,
but you can create things really quickly using this.
And you'll notice there's some dependencies
and we'll talk about this later too.
Create an atmospheric light, create a sky atmosphere,
create a volumetric light and create fog.
And you can be up and running pretty quickly
using this tool.
Everything gets connected automatically when you're using that
and makes it a lot easier.
And by default too, if you made it from scratch,
it would also have the same type of effect.
But that tool gets you up and running a little fast.
We'll talk about that tool later on too.
Let's go back to our Lumen example.
So if I go back into my Lumen example here,
we talked about how that directional light
can be connected to an atmospheric environment.
Now, one thing you do want to point out,
this is my default clouds that are set in here.
If you wanted to use volumetrics,
make sure that you turn them on
so you have more cloud options.
And you can find that here in your plugins.
So going back to our scene.
Now, we also have another light called the point light.
Now, if I bring my point light in,
I'm going to talk a little bit of the difference
between these lights and softening your shadows.
My point light's ready to go,
but say I want to maybe soften the shadows
that they're creating.
And you'll notice my shadows are a little bit jaggedy here
on the spotlight.
What I can do with this light,
as well as if I wanted to mess with my spotlight,
I can control a thing called our source radius.
As I increase that, you'll notice things get a bit softer
and we also get an actual physical yellow object
that pops up.
The same thing can occur when it comes to our point light.
I can control my source radius
and that can soften up my shadows.
And it works really well when it comes to Lumen.
Now you gotta be careful,
make sure you determine how strong you want that to be.
You can end up getting kind of a double shadow
or I should say a very blurred edge shadow.
That may be what you want and it may not.
So you just make sure you punch in the values
that you need.
You'll also notice when I bring the spotlight in here,
he has a few more other options here
and you will get that in certain light scenarios
where you have a thing called a soft source radius.
What that does, and we'll pick on the spotlight here,
that makes it so that you can go in here
and soften up that reflection.
So it isn't such a harsh object in your reflection.
So you won't have that hotspot type of circle in there.
I can soften that up a little bit.
There's also a thing called source length.
So if I went here with my spotlight,
I can also go in here and control my source length.
And you'll notice we've now changed the shape of that light.
So if I had office lighting, I can rotate this,
move this up, change my soft source radius
and my source radius a little bit.
Maybe make it a little bit smaller.
There you go.
And my soft source radius,
I don't have to worry about this too much
because again, it is the reflectivity primarily,
but the source length will be my primary.
Look here, you can almost make like a poor man's lightsaber
and they can move that up into the ceiling.
And if I had an object for that,
I could have it match the shape and size.
So that's actually kind of nice to have that.
There are a few more features in our lights
as we look at them.
As you can see in our spotlight,
we have outer cone angle and inner cone angle control
like you would any typical spotlight.
There's also temperature if you wanted to use temperature.
And does it affect world and cast shadows?
The same thing with our point light here,
as well as our rec.
I can go in here and control my shadows
and such things like does it affect the world
and we want to use temperature.
But you'll notice again, in that rec light that we had,
we had that shape control
when it came to our source width, source height,
but we also have a thing called barn door angle
where I can change that and almost have a focal
or a focus area.
Pretty nice.
So these are all really great lights to use
and everyone will have a different scenario
in which you will need them.
And again, don't mean to sound bias.
One of my favorites is this rec light
because it just works great
to be able to fill light quickly
and get it into the right position.
Another light, which if you were paying attention
and watching there,
I created a couple things that we have at our disposal.
One of them being the skylight.
And the skylight is very helpful.
If I turn that off,
you'll notice we'll be losing a lot of bounce light.
A lot of architectural companies will use this
as a quick way to get some bounce light
in your environment.
And in this case using Lumen,
you always want to make sure,
especially if you're grabbing stuff from the marketplace,
that the real-time capture is on.
You can also choose whether you want a cube map
and you can turn real-time capture off.
And if you wanted to,
you can do a specified cube map that you can load
and such things as HDR Haven has some free ones
that you can grab and load them quickly.
That's really up to you.
But the real-time one allows me to grab everything
within our scene, how our clouds are set,
how other different factors are in play,
and it's going to all be calculated automatically.
We can control resolution as well as threshold,
light color, and other things
to be able to actually get the scene
the way that we want.
You'll notice on each one of these lights,
there's going to be a mobility setting.
When you bring in a new light,
you want to make sure that it is movable.
Now I brought in this Rec light,
but we want them to be calculated correctly with Lumen.
And that requires that it's movable.
Static is more for baking, and so is stationary.
And Unreal will give you a preview on how those things work.
With Lumen active, our distant mesh fields
are already active, as well as our virtual shadow maps.
And that's Unreal out of the box.
But you do want to check things
and make sure that things are going in the right direction.
And we'll talk about that in our project settings next,
when we look at rendering and some of the things
you need to keep in mind when setting up Lumen.
We also can go here to our point light
and also switch this to movable.
And that's going to be helpful.
We also have HDR backdrop, if you wanted to use it,
and a sun in sky setup where you're using a compass,
and you can choose the time of day
if you want to punch that in
with latitude and longitude variables.
So again, when it comes to mobility,
static is going to be your baked indirect
and a direct lighting.
It is the cheapest to use.
And that's using our older bake system using light mass.
We also have stationary that also is to be used
with a baking scenario.
It's your baked indirect lighting
and allows characters to move around
and have shadows react to movement.
And then that stationary will be able to be used for it
and we'll have GI with it,
as well as static will also have GI,
but it will not react to any moving objects.
You'll notice there is a limit to use max
for overlapping lights.
And that's really important to consider
when it comes to working with baked lighting.
Unreal will let you know,
and then you'll have to manage accordingly.
And you can see that through the viewer,
or I should say view modes.
The highest quality medium performance hit
is what you'll get with this particular light.
Now movable is the most expensive
because that is a fully dynamic light with shadows.
It has the highest performance cost
and no indirect lighting.
In our case, we're using Lumen
and we're getting global illumination,
which is going to be great.
That means we're getting full bounce lighting
because it's using some of the ray tracing architecture
to be able to give us our dynamic global illumination
and believable lights within our scene in real time.
That's it with this section.
Here's some links to help you
understand the concepts of it more.
In the next section, we're going to dive deeper
into Lumen and how to use it and how it actually works.